ROWAN FLAD: My name is Rowan Flad.
I'm a faculty member in the
anthropology department here.
And I work on archeology in China.
And so what I'm going to tell
you a little bit about today
is a prediction method, a divination
process, that was used in early China.
In particular, I'm going to be talking
about a period in Chinese history
at the beginning of the dynastic
cycle, so about 3,500 years ago.
And associated with a dynasty
called the Shang Dynasty.
Have any of you ever heard
of the term oracle bones?
Oracle bones often
bring to mind writing.
And the reason for that is that
the first inscriptions known
from China, first writing we
know from Chinese contacts
and the first historical documents
we have, come from bones like these.
And so the documents
that we have, that mark
the beginning of the
historical record in China,
are divination records
for the most part.
And they are records that document
a series of questions or issues
that the Shang Court wanted to know
more information about from the spirit
world around them.
Inscriptions were first
identified by an aristocrat that
lived in the very end of the 19th
century, beginning of the 20th century,
named Wang Yirong.
And he was sick and had
some member of his household
go to the apothecary to get what were
sometimes referred to as dragon bones.
These were essentially bones that were
found in an archaeological context that
would then be ground up into
powder and added into medicine.
And those powders were thought
to be beneficial to one's health.
So he sent somebody out, and they
brought back some bones like this one.
And what we have on here
is an inscription that's
a fragment of a divination record.
Wang Yirong recognized
that this was writing
because he was a scholar himself.
He recognized that there were
some similarities to characters
that he knew from archaic contexts.
And he started to compile these,
buy them up from apothecaries all
over the place.
We learned a lot about
the Shang based on these.
And what we've learned
mostly about is what
the Shang Royalty were most concerned
about, and they were divining about.
Each of these divinations,
divination inscriptions,
has several different sections.
They don't all have it, but a complete
one has several different sections.
It has a date on it,
which is very important.
Now these are not absolute dates.
They are dates in a cycle of 60 days.
So there's a 60-day cycle.
And each of these inscription
when they're complete,
will have two characters
at the beginning of it
that mark the date
within the 60-day cycle.
Then they will tell you about who it is
that was responsible for the divining.
And then after that, there's a charge.
There's basically a topic about
which the diviners wanted to know.
And then what would
have happened, is you
would have had diviners
who recorded the dates,
they recorded the topics that they
were divining about, not on the bones
initially, then they
wait to see what happens,
and then they record the
result. And then all of that
is inscribed onto the
bones in certain cases.